special containment procedures do not
access
chapter one
manor house
item number
null
object class
contained
special containment procedures
the department of analytics has been
tasked with the annual procurement of
seven civilians to witness procedures
seven-fold they are to be promptly
delivered to the albright manor on
october 30th their biological profiles
are to be submitted to the medical
department not less than three weeks
beforehand for analysis each witness
must be sedated such that they awaken at
approximately midnight on october 31st
procedures
typically runs its course before sunrise
all entrances to the albright manor have
been sealed barred and boarded up the
sole exception is the underground shaft
used to deposit each witness it is
concealed within the house's cellar the
change remained taught
the albright manner has been fitted
throughout with surveillance devices for
personnel to witness procedures
sevenfold through to completion a
command post situated off-site shall be
staffed with no more than one
containment specialist and two d-class
personnel they are to be given false
containment procedures the containment
specialist will relay the events within
the matter as they transpire and may be
supplanted by a class d if the need
arises
for ethics committee mandate personnel
who survived the night are to be
terminated by the introduction of sarin
compounds into the outpost
on november 1st a cleanup crew shall be
dispatched to remove the remains of
every witness if indeed possible if
difficulties are experienced during
retrieval all bodies are to be
considered the possession of the
albright manor they will be integrated
into future events successfully
retrieved corpses are to be incinerated
in the crematorium behind the property
noise cancelling headphones will be
provided to personnel manning the
incinerator
for the remainder of the year personnel
are to remain wary of any surfaces which
contain the phrase this is where i died
special containment procedures produced
by s andrew swann
russia do not proceed
chapter 2
you complete me
description
the scattered remains of a miss
jacqueline hallcroft are affected by
several disparate anomalies the effects
began at an unspecified time after her
assault and murder at the hands of six
unknown assailants on 06 june 2006 and
persist through to this day firsthand
accounts of those affected by these
anomalies suggest that neutralization of
the effects would occur should each part
of ms holcroft be collected and laid to
rest
persons in the vicinity of any of miss
holcroft's remains who are privy to the
nature of the crime leading to her death
may become subject to its effects
this entails
visual hallucinations
subjects uniformly report seeing a nude
disheveled woman with deep lacerations
along her extremities these wounds are
consistent with those suffered by miss
hallcroft upon her dismemberment most
often the figure appears in one's
peripheral unmoving clutching its
midsection it disappears when one
attempts to look more closely
auditory hallucinations
these consist primarily of
unintelligible whispers and moans on
rare occasions subjects can discern
pleading and begging in these cases
subjects are typically called for by
name six subjects have reported hearing
an unfamiliar song sung to the tune of
twinkle twinkle little star
and finally olfactory hallucinations
namely the scent of amniotic fluid
affection by miss holcroft's remains
persist until the subject's death
typically this is expedited by the
development of secondary effects that
manifest upon the bi-annual anniversary
of the subject's exposure secondary
effects include but are not limited to
the discovery of body parts organs
fingers eyes teeth and hair will be
found at random near the subject they
are usually found upon opening a drawer
lifting a toilet seat and in other
concealed locations such as under the
subject's pillow or in their meals all
such objects disappear when unobserved
the insertion of a filthy nude woman
into all media depicting the subject
often obscured or in the distance
analysis of clear depictions has
revealed that said woman is in actuality
the reassembled amalgamation of miss
hallcroft's remains besides the wounds
reflecting her dismemberment there is a
single large vertical gash beginning
between her breasts and trailing down
towards her genitalia
an irrational fear that the chains are
weakening
sleep paralysis during such sessions
subjects have reported the presence of
multiple shadowy figures which hold down
and mutilate them unilaterally before
regaining full consciousness and control
of their bodies subjects claim to feel a
searing pain in their gut and the
removal of a vital component of their
being
update
by tracking reports of anomalous
activity and civilian deaths all 206
bones of ms holcroft's body have been
recovered the remains have been interred
in the holcroft family plot in creche
glen upon the conclusion of funiary
services all attendants to the service
suffered spontaneous disembowelment
since this time living subjects
previously affected by ms holcroft's
remains have reported cessation of
anomalous phenomena however each has
proven to be sterile furthermore one in
six subjects with living offspring has
reported the disappearance of one of
their children despite our best efforts
none of these children have been
recovered
it should be noted that this had no
effect on ms hullcroft's presence within
the albright manner
description produced by researcher
taloran
exploration caution do not continue
chapter 3
when the man comes around
exploration video log
locale crash glen kansas
population approximately 3125
[Music]
note
5 members of mobile task force epsilon 5
pentacle were deployed to the town of
crash glen following its subsumption by
a thick fog and the seeming
disappearance of all of its inhabitants
the following is a record of the
phenomena occurring within the town as
recorded by joe bates epsilon 5 echo
surveillance camera
begin log
camera activates epsilon 5 echo is
seated in the back seat of the task
force's humvee tentacle members perform
a perfunctory mic check as they pull up
to the perimeter of the town after two
minutes of idle chatter it is decided
that they should proceed via vehicle the
chains in the road break easily beneath
the humvee's wheels
epsilon 5 echo watches out the window as
the surrounding forest gives way to a
thick blanket of mist visibly
drastically reduces and epsilon 5 bravo
slows the vehicle to a crawl after
creeping force several meters through
the fog it is decided that exploration
should occur on foot epsilon 5 bravo
pulls to the side of the road
all passengers disembark epsilon 5 bravo
kills the engine and follows suit
very little can be discerned as epsilon
5 echo looks around a black sedan lay
just north of their position it is
laying on its side perpendicular to the
road and the roof has been torn free to
the right sits an ivy-coated brick
building behind a rusted chain-link
fence nothing can be seen beyond the
sidewalk across the street from their
position
the unit draws their firearms and form a
defensive position beside the humvee
while epsilon 5 charlie employs imaging
hardware epsilon 5 bravo teases epsilon
5 delta after the latter complains of
the silence within the once bustling
town of their birth epsilon 5 alpha
admonishes the siblings and calls for
professionalism the pair
acquiesce both thermal imaging hardware
and a modified sbid visual asset are
incapable of penetrating the fog beyond
what can already be seen with the naked
eye epsilon 5 alpha announces the
decision to continue without visual aid
due to the efficacy of natural sight and
the needless burden of excess hardware
epsilon 5 echo is called upon to
investigate the wrecked vehicle her hand
crosses the camera feed as she whispers
a prayer she sets off the car can be
heard to still be running as she
approaches beneath the sound of the
engine an indiscernible country song is
heard playing on the radio
besides its missing roof there is
extensive damage to the driver's side
rear which is missing its door there is
a large amount of blood on both the
dashboard and the now deflated passenger
side airbag as she closes in the music
becomes clearer it's a johnny cash tune
the singing and guitar cease and there
is a bit of static as the musician
quotes a bible verse before the radio
falls silent
close inspection reveals that all
seatbelts beside the tattered front
passengers remain strapped in and locked
including the four-point harness on the
child's car seat situated behind the
driver's chair epsilon 5 echo turns to
relay her findings to the rest of the
team
epsilon 5 charlie is absent
epsilon 5 echo makes an exclamation
regarding his disappearance
causing alarm amongst the others it is
not noted by epsilon 5 echo but on the
lower left of the feed there can be seen
a quasi-humanoid figure crouching
beneath the humvee it skitters swiftly
and silently backward and out of sight
on five four limbs epsilon five alpha
calls for the order he rallies the team
and takes point as the group travel down
the street and into town the four move
in step with epsilon 5 echo guarding the
rear down the side of the road the team
is guided by epsilon 5 delta to cut
through an alleyway
a low bellowing sound trumpets from on
high
the team emerges on the next street and
past several buildings there is a
barbershop whose window is shattered it
is dark inside
save for a flickering of a single light
near the back of the parlor that reveals
signs of struggle next to this a
destroyed building smokes with the last
embers of a raging fire
epsilon 5 delta and epsilon 5 bravo
reminisce over the loss of this
structure which was purportedly their
favorite pizzeria growing up epsilon 5
echo speaks over their conversation
questioning aloud being lack of bodies
epsilon 5 bravo shoots back with a
sarcastic response before the trio is
silenced by alpha who hears something
a quiet bleeding can be heard from
somewhere in the distance as the group
progresses a squat figure can be seen
and shrouded in the mist across the
street epsilon 5 alpha advances with his
weapon at the ready
they come upon a lamb laying in the
grass in the front yard of a two-story
home the number five is painted on its
fleece in blue paint the animal bleeds
and cries and is clearly distressed by
their presence it shakily stands as if
to flee but quickly collapses dried
blood spots the ground about the area it
lays in
epsilon 5 delta approaches the animal to
tend to it and is mocked with feigned
annoyance by her brother she discovers
that the lamb has something small and
metallic lodged into each of its hind
hooves causing it a great deal of pain
and prohibiting escape
epsilon 5 echo pens about their
surroundings with a rifle at the ready
while epsilon 5 delta kneels next to the
creature petting and comforting it the
fog holds not beyond an abandoned pickup
truck she asks if it might be best to
euthanize the lamb at this in the
camera's peripheral it can be seen to be
violently convulsing from the neck up
epsilon 5 delta is looking at her squad
later as this occurs
and is thus not immediately aware of the
sudden threat to her person
epsilon 5 echo turns with a start as
epsilon 5 bravo shouts to his sister who
sees the beast's behavior and recoils
she falls scooting backwards across the
lawn epsilon 5 alpha has his weapon
trained on the animal and fires epsilon
5 echo raises her weapon but does not
have a clear shot over the retreating
epsilon 5 delta
despite suffering extensive damage to
its midsection and spilling its guts
over the soft earth the animal remains
upright and continues to convulse and
bleed and scream its screams quickly
take on a human sound which then
devolves into the vocalizations made by
bodies in the albright manners
crematorium epsilon 5 bravo reaches down
to help his twin to her feet
she screams
epsilon 5 bravo catches his sister as
she falls back her feet seem locked in
position epsilon 5 echo lowers her
weapon and rushes to epsilon 5 delta's
side looking down a pair of thick metal
implements have risen through the soil
piercing both epsilon 5 delta's fate
each of the foreign objects has a thick
round head that would not allow them to
pull her up off them epsilon 5 echo
hurriedly explains this as she grips
around the head of one of the objects
and attempts to pry it upward and out of
her teammate
epsilon 5 alpha continues to deliver
concentrated fire into the entity as its
screams grow in volume mirrored cries
can be heard in the distance from
multiple sources epsilon 5 bravo
cradling his sister cries out an
expletive he draws his sidearm with a
free hand and flails it about shakily at
unseen foes epsilon 5 alpha reloads his
weapon
epsilon 5 echo looks up from her task
the entity is now an unrecognizable
bloodied husk it rears up leathery wings
unfurl from behind the creature it beats
its wings and begins to rise as it does
so it can be seen that its hind legs are
dug into the earth epsilon 5 echo shouts
out reassuringly as she doubles her
efforts to free your teammate
the metallic implements pull downward
severing the tip of epsilon 5 echo's
right index finger the ground gives way
as epsilon 5 delta is pulled ankle deep
into the earth epsilon 5 bravo drops his
weapon and seizes his sister under the
arms and she is dragged knee-deep into
the ground epsilon 5 echo tries to
assist in pulling her free as they
struggle the entity can be seen beating
its wings furiously it has raised itself
half a meter above ground it's straining
and pulling its grossly elongated hind
legs which remain embedded in the soil
epsilon 5 delta is pulled waist deep
bleeding can be heard all around the
team
epsilon 5 alpha orders the pair to
abandon epsilon 5 delta and requests
covering fire short concentrated bursts
are fired by the squad leader into
multiple areas at shadowy figures around
the fog epsilon 5 delta cries and
screams for help as she is pulled up to
her chest causing the pair to lose the
grip around her torso epsilon 5 echo
draws her sidearm aims it at epsilon 5
delta and shouts her intention to
decommission and spare the agent epsilon
5 bravo who is now locked hand in hand
with his sister pulling with all his
might threatens epsilon 5 echo with her
life if she pulls the trigger
several lambs become visible from within
the fog each slowly limps towards the
group epsilon 5 alpha again orders his
subordinates to retreat as he defends
them against the approaching threat
epsilon 5 delta is pulled steadily
deeper her head and arms remain just
above the ground epsilon 5 echo requests
permission to fire from epsilon 5 alpha
epsilon 5 bravo roars in defiance there
is a soft rumble as epsilon 5 delta is
rapidly dragged underground losing his
grip epsilon 5 bravo is pulled forward
and falls face first as he screams and
begins to dig at the ground epsilon 5
echo turns to see the entity rise higher
and higher up off the ground pulling its
hind legs out of the earth
its hooves much like the beast's hind
legs are seen to be elongated they
glisten with a metallic sheen as it
rises human feet can be seen being
brought up speared to the hooves the
nude form of epsilon 5 delta is slowly
unearthed her body is limp epsilon 5
bravo shouts a string of obscenities
retrieves his rifle and opens fire the
beast shudders as it takes more damage
it flies unsteadily carrying epsilon 5
delta's body up and over the team its
upper body becomes enshrouded in the
mist all that can be seen is epsilon 5
delta's corpse swaying as the beast
carries it
it bleeds rocking its hooves backward
before rapidly bringing them forward it
slams epsilon 5 delta's body into a
nearby telephone pole where she is
pinned by the feet what remains of the
entity and the lambs now surrounding the
team dissipate into the fog as the
trumpets bellow again
epsilon 5 alpha radios command to
deliver a sit rep and is given orders to
continue their descent into town epsilon
5 echo is preoccupied with bandaging her
finger against protest from epsilon 5
alpha epsilon 5 bravo attempts to ascend
the telephone pole to dislodge his
sister's corpse he fails in scaling the
structure and after two more attempts
heeds epsilon 5 alpha's orders
the trio depart
they carefully trek through the
neighborhood for the next 20 minutes
guided by epsilon 5 bravo's direction
the final chaotic moments of the town
become more apparent as they walk
onwards multiple vehicular accidents dot
the roads and lawns of the suburbs home
and auto alarms ring out in the distance
fog mixes with smoke from structure
fires
weaving is heard intermittently
no source is found
it is as the remaining members of
pentagon pass through a wrought iron
fence that epsilon 5 alpha reports a
stench of decay epsilon 5 bravo
expresses concern though it cannot be
seen from their position on the sidewalk
beside the fence epsilon 5 bravo
explains that they are passing by the
town's elementary school epsilon 5 alpha
swears a human outline becomes visible
ahead of them against the fence under
the shade of a tree
it becomes clear as they approach that
there are several such figures straddled
to the fence under the shade of a
weeping willow whose branches extend
over the fence from the school grounds
each figure is seen to be naked and
unmoving the trio carefully keep their
distance leaving the sidewalk and
circling into the street around the
figures there are five in total their
bodies can be seen to be tied by the
wrists to the fence and held upright
each is in various states of decay and
their backsides are torn and bloodied
with large gashes cutting across each
corpse the cause of death is speculated
by epsilon 5 echo to be from
flagellation
the corpse in the center is noted to be
fresher than those on either side of it
and the wounds on its back possess a
different appearance than the others
inciting inquiry by the team epsilon 5
bravo walks towards it he pulls out his
canteen opens it and pours water over
the body enough blood is washed away to
reveal what remains of a tattoo on the
body's upper back it is the insignia of
epsilon 5 pentacle identifying the
corpse as the missing epsilon 5 charlie
the lacerations can be seen to have been
precisely struck in order to spell out a
single phrase
this is where i died
epsilon 5 alpha forbids further action
with the corpse epsilon 5 echo watches
as epsilon 5 bravo backs away from the
bodies as he turns to join his teammates
a thick horned vine descends from the
bow of the willow tree it quickly
ensnares epsilon 5 bravo around his
cranium drawing blood epsilon 5 bravo
drops his canteen and attempts to rest
himself free but he is pulled sharply
upward and out of sight splintering
bones can be heard over his screams both
sounds are short-lived before the
trumpets bellow again blood and viscera
spill from the treetop epsilon 5 alpha
grabs epsilon 5 echo by the shoulder and
the pair retreat
the agents run down the street in the
direction they came from bleeding and
screaming can be heard in response to
this though the agents encounter no
obstacles without the guidance of the
twins and due to environmental stressors
the agents make a wrong turn after
several minutes they carry along a side
street which leads towards the town's
center against their knowledge
at the edge of their perception on all
sides faces can be briefly seen in the
fog they coalesce for about a moment
before losing all cohesion appearing
elsewhere distant weeping can again be
heard sobbing becomes laughter the faces
in the mist leer unseen by the agents as
they run
cruel and mocking laughter grows in
intensity as the pair progress something
large stirs underneath beginning to be
free from its shackles epsilon 5 alpha
howls with rage brandishes its sidearm
and fires at nothing epsilon 5 echo
pauses she begs her squad leader to
compose himself and soldier on he's
behaving erratically and refuses to
listen to reason she threatens to leave
him behind yet he does not comply she
runs off on her own epsilon 5 alpha's
shouts and gunshots ring out for the
next few minutes over the bleeding and
the laughing and the weeping
the trumpets bellow again
all is silent
epsilon 5 echo continues cutting through
the cul-de-sac and several properties
before tripping over something embedded
in the ground she screams looking down
it can be seen that she's injured her
leg and is bleeding after a moment she
comes to a stand panning about it
becomes clear she has stumbled into a
cemetery she curses thrice under her
breath immediately apologizes and says a
quick prayer
she hobbles through the cemetery
occasionally using headstones for
support before her the outline of the
church becomes visible she circles the
building coming around to the front the
stairs are shakingly navigated as she
pushes open the front door collapsing
once within
there exists no fog within the structure
the entirety of its interior is able to
be envisaged epsilon 5 echo looks about
the church everything is in perfect
order in stark contrast to the chaos
throughout the town proper in taking in
her surroundings epsilon 5 echo becomes
fixated on the large cross behind the
pulpit the figure nailed to it is moving
she stands and closes distance
it is epsilon 5 alpha
his fatigues and equipment are absent a
tunic is wrapped around his midsection
he coughs as epsilon 5 echo approaches
blood and nails are expelled from his
mouth as he does so as epsilon 5 echo
reaches out towards her squad leader his
eyes open there is a blinding light
coming from them there is a noise of
thunder the very foundation of the
building shakes with his sound an
epsilon 5 echo stumbles backwards she
runs for the door as epsilon 5 alpha
bleeds behind her
now outside epsilon 5 echo looks about
in a panic she descends the stairs
rushing to get off the church's property
rumbling can be heard behind her turning
she can see that the nearest graves have
collapsed hands and fingers grip the
edges of the ones closest to her epsilon
5 echo continues as fast as her injury
will allow
she nears the street in front of the
house of warship and falls to her knees
she tries to stand and finds she is
unable heavy footsteps become audible
the earth quakes with each step she
cries and begs forgiveness she begins to
pray
her prayers are interrupted as she lets
out a wet gurgling sound she looks down
revealing a long bladed instrument
embedded in her side her camera feed
begins to raise up the ground is lost
beneath the shroud of fog there exists
no point of reference within the fog to
discern how high the agent is raised
before she is turned about to face and
behold a massive human figure
it brings her up to meet its gaze though
its eyes are enshrouded in shadow its
bearded face is gaunt the agent
struggles as the entity brings her
closer to its face the level of
proximity reveals that the entirety of
its countenance is comprised of
countless human bodies the false beast
opens its maw from the depths of its
being
a roiling thunder can be heard
the trumpets bellow again
and log
exploration produced by dr
warning pangiatopoulos and desist
chapter four
the exorcism of savannah grace
interview
exorcism attempt number four
date fourteenth of april 2004
present
dr peter mcneil department of demonology
psychology division
agent savannah grace mobile task force
mu 13 ghostbusters purification
specialist background during the course
of operation four monarchs the details
of which are classified level four agent
grace was exposed to a demonic entity
and suffered possession it has since
been determined that this accident was
due to a failure of the chains to hold
what lies beneath agent was subsequently
taken to the department of demonology
for exorcism but initial attempts failed
at expulsion dr peter mcneil a
specialist in exorcism via demonic
psychology was then authorized to meet
with the possessed alone to attempt
exorcism via coercion or intimidation
recording commences
hello agent great
you've been fairly quiet since the last
attempt
jim connor i know you can still hear me
eyes up
matthew
you repeat those names in a feat of
resistance but you know that it was your
own actions that led to their deaths it
was your fault
you must give me nerve recompense you
must cease your struggle
yet look at yourself now
you are locked up deep in this facility
you know you cannot escape you know that
you will never achieve your goals your
desires your hopes you will die here
alone
my mercy
you will experience hell for all time
should i so choose
you will give in you will let go
you are still resisting
you will be punished for that
will you not rather flee to what refuge
i dame to offer you
save your breath
you will not be aided you will not be
believed
you will be reviled
is
is that really the lord's prayer
backward are you truly so useless so
vile so pathetic and so utterly weak
that you would resort to such a petty
trick as your final
are such a defiance of the lord your
nature and actions so disgrace
then perhaps you know this deuteronomy 4
4
but all of you who held fast to the
villagers
[Music]
you will finish the verse but all of you
who held fast
you're slipping
but all of you who held fast to the
lord
your god are still alive today good girl
see i have taught you decrees and laws
as lord my god
command
so that
you may follow
and recording
interview produced by dr menard
incident online warning containment
chapter 5
digital ash in a digital urn
incident timeline
the following is the recorded history of
all anomalous phenomena relating to
prodigy priest king
since its release included are the
research team's findings of events prior
to foundation involvement has gleaned
through interviews notable breakthroughs
and claims made by the game's fan
community has tracked through usenet and
phenomena observed by play testers in a
controlled foundation environment
for ease of reference subjects shall be
color coded according to the empathic
role ascribed to them by the anomaly
key
profile alpha blue
profile red theta
and profile green
omega
29th of november 1988
axelrodimer blue age nine of loyalton
california experiences feeling of
numbness in his hands throughout the
school day he is permitted to rest in
the nurse's office for an hour and loses
all sensation below the wrist by noon
axel is checked out of the school at 12
33 by his mother while on route to the
hospital axel's condition improves the
parent travels home with axel's mother
attributing the condition to the
previous night's extended play session
todd wilson red age 27 of dallas texas
returns his copy of prodigy priest king
to the babbages where he purchased it mr
wilson asserted that once entering the
main location
labyrinth all audio cuts off with the
silence being punctuated by a prolonged
low rumble a replacement copy was
provided
d hammond blue age 12 of durham new
hampshire is spotted standing by the
side of the road in front of her home in
the pouring rain
fixated on the full moon her neighbor
ushers her back towards her house and
alerts her parents
30th of november 1988
ken klein blue age 18 of colorado
springs colorado experiences an
uncharacteristic severe depressive
episode and is only assuaged by the
embrace of his father
triplets marcus michael and matthew cook
blue age 15 are reported absent from
school they have locked themselves in
their bedroom where they have scrawled a
top-down representation of a map to the
game's main location labyrinth on the
walls the phrase this is where i died is
carved in the corner of the room
1st of december 1988
mary belvin's green age 33 of bristol
pennsylvania destroys her son's copy of
prodigy priest king owing to the
latter's single-minded preoccupation
with playing it to the point of soiling
himself during play at around three
o'clock she enters the basement to fetch
laundry and falls down the stairs she
suffers a fatal cervical fracture upon
landing
axelrodimer blue is unable to get out of
bed on account of full-body numbness he
has rushed to the emergency room
leo rasmussen blue age 3 of idabel
oklahoma seizes and becomes comatose
while watching his elder sibling play
prodigy priest king he is hospitalized
alt binaries ppk news group is
established on newsnet for pulling
knowledge about the game several users
expressed frustration in being unable to
find the mirror the jewel or the sword
user tran uploads several phonographs of
their computer screen showcasing a
glitch of the ghoul enemy sprite entity
a blue this glitch makes the enemy
appear much shorter compared to other
sprites and gives it blackened skin with
flecks of red
track claims it can neither be killed
nor interacted with but may block access
to crucial areas of the game
necessitating a reset six other users
claimed to experience the same glitch
[Music]
2nd of december 1988
gina wilson arrives at her son todd's
home colored red after he misses two
days of work at the family's shop she is
unable to open his bedroom door and
hears a low blaring monotone chiptune on
the other side police arrive by 233 and
force their way through the barricaded
door they find the mattress propped up
against the window and all lights
shattered the only remaining source of
light is from the monitor displaying a
game over screen it does not respond to
the attempts to turn it off and must be
unplugged todd red is not found
user jean-luc picard uploads four images
to the ppk news group revealing a hidden
tunnel in the southeastern corner of the
labyrinth the path therein leads to a
small colorful room resembling a child's
bedroom which is anachronistic to the
game's fantasy setting in one image
entity a blue stands in the corner
facing a wall the jewel item
representing the prodigy can be found on
the nightstand
3rd of december 1988
several users in the ppk news group that
have attained the jewel report the
presence of a new enemy entity b
red encountered in the crypt portion of
the game which is not referenced in the
game manual the dark robed humanoid
flees from the player upon approach
players find that entity b
red can be attacked if cornered and if
killed will collapse into a quivering
heap on the ground it regenerates after
three seconds which players exploit for
easy experience points
d hammond blue is found by her mother
sitting in the fetal position in the
corner of her bedroom crying and shaking
twins cindel and mandy's shields pink
are discovered within their parents
basement they are found reciting the
song twinkle twinkle little star
incessantly the lyrics are wrong
ray gonzalez red age 24 of brunswick new
jersey is found by police in his home he
has been bludgeoned to death his eyes
hands and genitals were violently
removed pre-mortem and a quarter-meter
rod is found inserted in his anal cavity
bryce stephenson age six is rescued from
the basement
4th of december 1988.
user triceratop begins a sub-thread to
the ppk news group to discuss her
experience with the game stating that
the ghost enemies are vocalizing her
name as opposed to default soundbytes
most users respond with skepticism with
one exception triple h who claims to
experience the same issue
the parents of marcus michael and
matthew cook all blue invite father
emmet clark red into their home for
council regarding their son's erratic
behavior when the priest enters the
bedroom alongside the boy's father
stephen cook green
fulfilling profiles alpha theta and
omega mrs cook's 9-1-1 call is
intercepted and mobile task force
tierfing black arrives 10 minutes later
they are able to discreetly shift the
mass into a mobile containment vehicle
for study at site-99 it spontaneously
combusts once placed on the examination
table father clark red and mr cook green
survive for several minutes afterward
before the former expires due to cranial
trauma mr cook green
then grips the edge of the table and
pulls causing the mask to fall to the
ground it lands in such a way as to
sever his cervical vertebrae killing him
instantly a copy of prodigy priest king
is extracted from the abdomen of either
michael or matthew cook blue
kevin klein's speech blue has rendered
near incomprehensible outside of simple
phrases and his motor functions have
become impaired a large tumor is
discovered growing behind his parietal
lobe
5th of december 1988
jeb swiftwater blue age 15 of new york
relates to his psychiatrist a recurring
nightmare and accompanying sleep
paralysis he has been experiencing over
the previous few nights wherein he
expires in a house fire
user thrice denies red claims that he
had to restart his game as all text and
dialogue had been replaced with the
phrase this is where i died inhibiting
their ability to solve a puzzle in
cavern
user tret
is the first player to have reached
hedge maze they claim that the music on
this stage is bugged as it is
periodically interrupted by a loud
snapping noise
subject d999 blue retrieves the jewel
item the screen goes blank subject
convulses and expires upon dissection
malformed organs heart left kidney and
right lung are discovered that are not a
genetic match of the subject
6th of december 1988
progress updates from the ppk news group
drop off considerably due to the product
recall but a few members retain their
copies of the game user triceratop is
the second player to reach the hedge
maze and upload several images of
indiscernible object entity c green up
in the night sky
user tre obtains the sword representing
the king they progress to the final area
of the game but do not communicate what
this new area is
the remains of d hammond blue are
discovered by dr gifford the body is
preserved under a layer of hot ash a
sierpinski triangle is charred into the
linoleum
cries for help or heard coming from a
test chamber a doll is found within it
cries when disposed of
an audible snap is heard throughout site
33 researcher emily greene who had
overseen the previous night's play
testing is found to have hanged herself
in her quarters
7th of december 1988.
operatives in kansas arrive at the home
of sarah whitaker green use that handle
triceratop to retrieve the second to
last copy of prodigy priest king in
civilian possession agent myers suffers
third degree burns on his hands in
trying to separate her from the monitor
whitaker green is terminated at the
discretion of the team lead
using information gleaned from the ppk
news group subject d072
red reaches henchman's researchers can
corroborate claims of audio
abnormalities and the presence of entity
c green above the maze this humanoid
sprite can be seen to be hanged by the
neck with the rope extending up to the
sky beyond what can be viewed by the
player
d072 red refuses to play any further
when prompted to answer why he weeps and
begs for forgiveness
subject d-856 red acquires the mirror in
his playthrough
mobile task force see no evil arrives on
the site 30 minutes later to restore
order and isolate the creature sector 3
is subsequently evacuated and scuttled
no disciplinary action is taken against
the researchers and guards involved due
to their loss of agency several are
treated for fractures in their
metacarpal bones samples of the
creature's seminal fluid are sent to
biocite 87 for study
the ethics committee issues a mandate
prohibiting the use of test subjects
with a history of sexual offense
three distinct character profiles are
formulated for affected persons each
correlating with a different range of
anomalous effects
twins sindel and mandy's shields pink
are found dead broken chain links are
scattered about the vicinity of the
bodies
subject d9 acquires the sword he is now
able to progress to the final level of
the game tilted with a nonsensical
assortment of characters and symbols
sound cancelling gear is required for
the research staff
8th of december 1988.
subjects d72
red 147 blue and 9 green are found to be
absent from their respective cells
sloppy trails of blood and visceral lead
across the ground in the direction of
the test chambers terminating at the
point where the floor meets the wall
shattered glass a class ring and a shiv
respectively are discovered in the
remains axelrodimer blue is pronounced
dead by foundation clinicians following
a grand mal seizure despite the lack of
brain activity his body twitches over
the next half hour it then stands
approaches the attendant doctor and
embraces him
user tra makes a post detailing what
they believe to be the dungeon holding
the game's singular boss several
screenshots are included depicting a
darkened winding staircase with a stone
corridor user triceratop sarah whitaker
green response to this saying
this is where i dined
ken klein blue expires in site 42's
medical bay necropsy reveals the brain
tumor to be a developing brain
user tret posts an update to their
progress they claim to have traveled the
spiral staircase for three hours and in
spotting an irregularity in the inward
facing wall
they are able to clip their avatar
partially through the stone a screenshot
of their findings
all testing is subsequently aborted
efforts are increased to find and
identify this user before they can
confront the anomaly the chains have
become too few in number to hold it
9th of december
1988
despite never having any form of contact
with the anomaly
d126 red begins to regurgitate shards of
reflective glass and dies of blood loss
leoris mutant blue shows the first signs
of activity since he fell unconscious he
cries out hot too hot as his body
temperature rises above 38 degrees
celsius he quickly expires
the game over sound bite plays over the
pa systems of 70 individual secure
foundation locations as well as
countless civilian institutions
recreation centers and shopping
districts nationwide
several dozen ropes manifest over the
primary test site
site director swanson task force
commander shearden and senior researcher
ortega are hanged until dead upon
attempting escape the remaining senior
staff is similarly killed as the ropes
infiltrate the site through various
means clerical and custodial staff are
not targeted
user tret makes his final post to the
ppk news group insisting solely of the
phrase i found out where he died
incident timeline produced by researcher
smalls
[Music]
danger critical risk of containment
failure
chapter 6
plaything
testing log
procedure initial intake examination to
determine the presence of anomalous
phenomena the doll is seated on a chair
within the test chamber d002 introduced
to the environment and instructed to
remain still
description temperature within the
chamber drops by 2 degrees celsius the
doll plays a rendition of twinkle
twinkle little star albeit composed of
different lyrics
twin kill twin kill little stars robbed
of wonder torn and scarred rest above
the world so high two souls flit about
the night twin kill twin kill little
stars justice is not very far
despite the lack of any mechanical
components the object's eyes track d002
as he backs away from it and into a
corner
results
subject suffered from heart palpitations
on account of stress induced by the
interaction attending medical personnel
report a mild unease from viewing him
the reasoning for which was found to be
ineffable
procedure standard test to determine
potential sapience the doll is seated on
a chair within the chamber d002 is again
introduced he is instructed to attempt a
dialogue with the item
description after d002 greets the doll
it responds in kind calling d002 by his
birth name d002 immediately requests
access the item giggles until d002 is
extracted from the chamber
results subject's vinyls found to be
nominal his eyes were noted to be
particularly glassy and dry subject
reported that he had trouble blinking
procedure intent is to determine the
identity of the item and discern how
long until the chains fail to hold d002
reintroduced to the chamber equipped
with a questionnaire
description item identifies itself as
cindy item refuses to elaborate on its
intent or purpose instead the item
recounts the crime which led to d002's
incarceration faint screaming begins to
emanate from within the chamber with no
identifiable source steadily growing in
volume as the doll elaborates
the screaming suddenly stops it then
requests that d002 play with it d002
does not acquiesce the doll then
questions him regarding jacqueline
halcroft
he becomes adamant that he be released
from the chamber
results personnel report an implacable
feeling of terror upon envisioning d002
a medical examination discovers a two
millimeter cyst on the subject's back
the doctor performing the examination is
apprehensive towards lacerating it and
is granted personal leave
procedure purpose of this test is decors
more information from the item or the
entity inhabiting it a small table two
chairs a toy tea set and doilies are
prepared for the interaction
description d002 sits across from the
doll he pours her a cup of tea then
itself as instructed d002 begins the
session by exchanging pleasantries the
pair speak of the weather and of their
favorite teas several minutes into the
conversation d002 asks her how she came
to be in her present situation
she merely states that she exists to
fulfill a singular purpose and stares
pointedly at d002
she then begins in a name tangent
regarding the events unfolding in crash
glen
test aborted
results subject reported having trouble
moving its digits volunteer personnel
inspected its hands and found them both
to have their musculature locked up and
fixed in an open-handed grasping
position
furthermore it became increasingly
belligerent upon trying and failing to
scratch the cyst on its back which had
swollen considerably the decision was
made to lacerate it alongside a large
volume of pus the subject was found to
have a thin threaded filament hanging
from the interior of the cyst 20
millimeters were extracted before the
filament caught and retracted back into
d002's back causing it to scream
uncontrollably for its mother
procedure the item is introduced into
the test chamber with the instructions
to bargain with cindy her information it
is instructed to promise her foundation
support in fulfilling her mission in
exchange for sharing knowledge on
precisely what it entails
description the item is ushered into the
chamber having lost the use of its legs
once the door is sealed the item with
great trouble recites the script
prepared by personnel detailing the
foundation's intent in aid
cindy blushes she laughs at the item and
stands from her seat she approaches the
item staring it in the eyes and tells it
she already has everything she wants she
then requests the awaiting security
personnel to open the door for her they
comply dr carter offers to give her a
ride home citing the worry her parents
must be feeling and apologizes profusely
cindy is taken home to the albright
results
the item on screen was recovered from
the chamber
testing log produced by ih pikmin
recover dividends
chapter 7
scary stories to tell in the dark
recorded evidence
date 0101
2001
location yogi bear's jelly stone park
quarryville pennsylvania
discoveries one camper furnished for a
family of four situated at the campsite
there is no accompanying vehicle
a malnourished border collie laying
beside the camper became violent upon
collection
a stick one end skewers two marshmallows
the other is smoldering in the fire pit
a rosary belonging to savannah grace
a single chain rusted and near useless
three bloodied fingernails discovered by
a small stone embedded in the soil claw
marks are evident in the dirt for half a
meter from the direction of the camper
the remnants of several charred pieces
of paper within the fire pit
burned articles of clothing belonging to
an adult male found beneath the camper
tire treads belonging to an unidentified
pickup truck or suv leading away from
the area
date 1412 1988
location abdi residence calvert texas
discoveries
a tattered woman's nightgown caught in
the bushes beneath a second-story
bathroom window their footprints whose
placement indicates a slow and steady
gait lead through the mud towards the
street
parallel pairs of slashes rips and tears
in several pieces of furniture
throughout the living room which is in a
state of disarray an identical pair of
marks are scratched in the wall leading
from the bottom to the top of the
staircase
a flashlight triggered in the on
position the lens is cracked and it is
run out of batteries
three sleeping bags the first is soiled
with urine the second is torn asunder
with no remaining biological evidence
beside a solitary strand of hair the
third is zipped closed around a mound
originally thought to be one of the
missing persons
approximately five pounds of soil
analysis is able to determine it had
been sourced from crash glen
a tire iron located at the bottom of the
stairs adjacent to the living room in a
pool of bile
the door to the master bedroom laying in
the hallway the hinges are warped and
destroyed
the restroom within the master bedroom
is locked from the inside a single slip
of paper is found to have been inserted
beneath the door it was meant to be red
single child's toothbrush its handle
bloodied blood viscera and what is later
determined to be intraocular fluid are
found in the sink across from the open
window
date
11 11 2019
location cabin of renowned horror writer
earl studbach n
netherlands
discoveries
a single pair of boot prints in the snow
leading from the cabin and into the
wilderness the trail ends at a nearby
country road
victim's typewriter the l key is missing
a several hundred page manuscript atop
the workstation incinerated by
investigators
a loaded handgun laying on the floor
beside the victim's chair a single round
has been discharged
the final chapter
spirals
my new traces of blood bone fragments
and cerebral matter in the vicinity of
the workstation
a bundle of towels soaked in blood and
containing larger bone fragments
discovered among cleaning supplies
hidden beneath the bathroom sink
victim's trademark homburg hat was found
to have been stolen
date 31 10
2018
location
the home of hugh davis broadcasting
location of horror podcast witchinghour
manchester england
discoveries
splotches of a warm viscous fluid around
a shattered basement window
a cloud of smoke the lingering scent of
burning hair and scorched flesh
a cell phone belonging to the guest
vlogger contained a trigger
several ounces of ash concentrated
within countless handprints scattered
about the floor of the basement studio
orientation suggests a single point of
origin
a newspaper article regarding the
disappearance of identical twins sindel
and mandy
one digital camera that contained
footage recorded immediately after the
live stream was corrupted contents
viewed without sound by a soul operator
since euthanized
a wired lapel mic its entire length
covered in saliva
a desiccated husk of inverted human
epidermis the oral cavity is grossly
expanded
date
one two
one one location
judith montague memorial library ebb
brook wales
discoveries
shattered glass scattered about the
south-facing bay window most fragments
were stained with blood
something small and defenseless
originating from jacqueline hallcroft
11 dead birds various species cause of
death determined to be from internal
bleeding and bruising of the brain from
a collision with a structure
heavy infestation by muska domestica
numbering in the hundreds of thousands
library cards belonging to the six
victims indicated book club membership
five books found throughout the reading
area rotten beyond identification and
each found to contain genetic material
from their respective reader
low droning noise emanating throughout
the area a hymn in an unknown language
a trail of words in cursive script
written with an estimated 5 liters of
human blood it begins from the shattered
bay window and follows her out towards
the book depository across the street
one operative is lost
date 11 8
1914 location
allied trenches near swasan france
discoveries a collapsible spade found at
the bottom of a deep 11 meter shaft
entrenched alongside the soldiers held
position
three dog tags two were warped and
identifying information has been
scratched out
a single human eye found in the
possession of a rat
a severely damaged copy of prodigy
priest king
spent musicians and empty rifles a sweep
of the area reveals that most rounds
were fired into friendly territory
an unopened envelope containing an
illegible letter found in the mud
beneath the duck ports they will not be
missed
one meter of barbed wire caked in
viscera the uniform of one of the
missing soldiers is tangled within
11 teeth belonging to the only
identified soldier found at the bottom
of the pit coated in soil
a tunnel large enough for a grown man
extending from the bottom of the pit and
continuing for some several hundred
meters it ends upon meeting a trench in
enemy occupied territory
several more teeth found at regular
intervals within the tunnel
date 31 12 2011
location tai chi kazuo residents
discoveries black clouded water in all
basins samples of the fluid revealed the
particulate to be powdered bone mineral
extensive water damage in the room is
beneath and adjacent to the lavatory
copious amounts of one meter long human
hair black
the sound it makes when we burn each
witness in the crematorium
eleven mirrors ten are in various rooms
within the domicile shattered the last a
compact mirror is found untouched
all clothing and personal effects
belonging to six of the seven missing
participants neatly folded and arranged
100 extinguished candles gathered in the
center of the living quarters what
100 extinguished candles gathered in the
center of the living quarters could
extinguished candles 100 gathered in the
center of the living quarters have
100 extinguished candles gathered in the
center of the living quarters happened
100 extinguished candles gathered in the
center of the living quarters two
extinguished candles one hundred
gathered in the center of the living
quarters the
extinguished candles
gathered in the center of the living
quarters
bodies
candles
extinguished
gathered
living
[Music]
[Applause]
do not proceed
[Music]
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua
jaby
pure osmium
sciodiodemnatus
revenant
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbidge
longinus
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you